For over 30 years, five days a week, there was this thing on the radio called The Rest of the Story, just 3 and 1/2, 4 minutes long.
在超过30年的时间里，每周五天，广播里都有一个叫作《故事的余韵》（The Rest of the Story）的节目，时长只有3分半到4分钟。
It ran all over the country. Paul Harvey was the announcer. He did two other daily broadcasts that, if you ever heard them, you will never forget them-- the way he wrote, the way he sounded.
它在全国各地播出。保罗·哈维（Paul Harvey）是播音员。他还主持过另外两个每日广播节目，如果你曾经听过，就绝对不会忘记——他的写作方式，他说话的声音。
Hello, Americans. This is Paul Harvey. Stand by for news.
各位美国同胞，大家好。我是保罗·哈维。请收听新闻。
My first job in Chicago, making stories for NPR, my windows at the NPR Chicago bureau looked out over a section of East Wacker Drive that was called Paul Harvey Drive, which I loved, thinking that somewhere not far from where I was sitting Paul Harvey had been up since 3:30 in the morning, pounding out his scripts on an electric typewriter. At his height, he was on over 1,200 radio stations, which, by the way, is more stations than NPR has-- just a massive audience, 24 million.
我在芝加哥的第一份工作是为美国国家公共电台（NPR）制作报道，我在NPR芝加哥分社的窗户正对着东瓦克大道（East Wacker Drive）的一段，那里被称为保罗·哈维大道（Paul Harvey Drive），我非常喜欢这一点，因为我想到在我坐的地方不远处，保罗·哈维可能从凌晨3点半就起床了，正在用电动打字机敲击着他的稿件。在他事业的巅峰期，他有超过1200个电台在转播他的节目，顺便提一下，这比NPR拥有的电台数量还要多——受众极其庞大，达2400万人。
His daily show, Paul Harvey News and Comment, was the day's news delivered like brisk radio poetry with some folksy humor or some conservative opinion. But his show The Rest of the Story is what I want to talk about today. Typical episode, just jumps into the action.
他的每日节目《保罗·哈维新闻与评论》（Paul Harvey News and Comment）将当日新闻以干练的“广播诗”形式呈现，并带有某种乡土幽默或保守派观点。但我今天要谈的是他的《故事的余韵》节目。通常情况下，节目直接进入主题。
Now is the winter of Ted's discontent. You can see the frustration, even the anger in his face and in his gait as he stalked down Madison Avenue that blustery morning. He had thought himself, hoped himself a book author, a poet. But the great publishers of New York, New York had repeatedly demonstrated the error of his ways.
泰德（Ted）的郁闷之冬开始了。你可以看到他脸上的沮丧，甚至愤怒，还有他那天早上大步走过麦迪逊大道时那种沉重的步伐。他曾以为自己、曾希望自己能成为一名书作者、一名诗人。但纽约市的那些大出版商们已经反复证明了他的错误。
I have to say, listening to Paul Harvey makes me feel like I need to go back to radio school. He just has this incredibly musical sense of timing, of when to pause, when to take the pitch of his voice up and down, which he would do like a singer climbing up and down the scales. Listen to the way he performs the next few sentences as just one long sentence, including dialogue.
我不得不说，听保罗·哈维的节目让我觉得自己需要回炉重造去学广播。他有一种不可思议的音乐感和节奏感，知道何时停顿，何时升高或降低语调，就像歌手在音阶上攀升和下降一样。听听他是如何把接下来的几句话——包括对话——像一句长句子一样演绎出来的。
A volume of verse? Oh, no, no, no, no, no. Verse was not selling these days. Anyhow, Ted's particular volume was simply too different from others in its category. And worse still, it was too fantastic.
“一卷诗集？哦，不，不，不，不，不。诗集现在卖不动。总之，泰德这本诗集实在太与众不同了。更糟的是，它太天马行空了。”
Who sounds like that?
谁会发出那种声音？
Sorry, they had said. 27 times. 27 respected publishing houses had perused Ted's imagined masterpiece and rejected it, and not all of them politely.
他们说，很抱歉。27次。27家受人尊敬的出版机构仔细阅读了泰德那部想象中的杰作并拒绝了它，而且并非都很有礼貌。
Ted learned his lesson. He decided he's going to go home and had a plan for his manuscript.
泰德吸取了教训。他决定回家，并对他的手稿有了一个计划。
And he was going to vent his aggravation by burning that document, a bonfire of the inanities.
他打算通过烧掉那份稿件来发泄他的挫败感，一场关于愚蠢思想的篝火。
Nice tip of the hat there to the title of a Tom Wolfe novel, or possibly to 15th-century church history. Then Ted runs into a guy he knew from school, Mike McClintock, there in Madison Avenue. And Mike invites him up to his office.
这里向汤姆·沃尔夫（Tom Wolfe）小说标题致敬，或者可能指的是15世纪的教会历史。然后泰德在麦迪逊大道上遇到了他在学校时认识的一个人，麦克·麦克林托克（Mike McClintock）。麦克邀请他去办公室坐坐。
Well, Mike's new office, the establishment by which he had been hired only three hours earlier, was Vanguard Press, a publisher, and more significant, a publisher Ted had somehow overlooked. And you have guessed the rest. Ted did get published. And he got famous. And later, he would marvel, "If I'd been going down the other side of Madison Avenue that morning, I'd be in the dry cleaning business instead."
好吧，麦克的新办公室——他仅仅在三小时前才受雇于的那家机构——是先锋出版社（Vanguard Press），一家出版商，更重要的是，这是一家泰德不知何故忽略了的出版商。你已经猜到了结局。泰德确实出版了作品。而且他出名了。后来，他感叹道：“如果那天早上我走的是麦迪逊大道的另一侧，我现在可能就在干洗店工作了。”
For once upon a grotesque disappointment in the winter of 1937, following an intolerable 27 turndowns by the high priests of the publishing industry of New York, there was a little volume on the verge of incineration entitled And To Think That I Saw It on Mulberry Street. And that was followed by Horton Hatches the Egg. And that was followed by How the Grinch Stole Christmas. Then came The Cat in the Hat, and Green Eggs and Ham, and The Lorax. Of course, you know their creator as Ted Geisel. You know him by his pen name, Dr. Seuss. Only now you know the rest of the story.
因为在1937年那个郁闷的冬天，在经历了出版业高层祭司们不可容忍的27次拒绝之后，曾经有一本小书正处于被焚毁的边缘，书名为《我想我在桑树街上看到它了》（And To Think That I Saw It on Mulberry Street）。随后的作品有《霍顿孵蛋》（Horton Hatches the Egg）。再后来是《格林奇偷走圣诞节》（How the Grinch Stole Christmas）。接着是《戴帽子的猫》（The Cat in the Hat）、《绿鸡蛋和火腿》（Green Eggs and Ham）以及《罗拉克斯》（The Lorax）。当然，你知道他们的创作者是泰德·盖泽尔（Ted Geisel）。你通过他的笔名苏斯博士（Dr. Seuss）认识他。现在，你知道了故事的余韵。
Lots of episodes of The Rest of the Story are like this one, about somebody who fails at something for a long time, and then there's a lucky break, and everything changes. So for example, there's this skinny, shy, lonely kid who gets beat up till a fireman teaches him to stand and fight. And they became--
《故事的余韵》中有很多剧集都像这一集一样，讲述某人在某件事上长期失败，然后遇到了转机，一切都改变了。例如，有一个瘦弱、害羞、孤独的孩子，他一直被欺负，直到一位消防员教他站起来反击。他们成为了——
The two-fisted, ultimately tough screen legend you knew as John Wayne.
那位硬汉，最终成为了你所熟知的银幕传奇人物约翰·韦恩（John Wayne）。
There's the 14-year-old boy who writes to Franklin Delano Roosevelt asking for $10, who turns out to be--
还有一个14岁的男孩写信给富兰克林·德拉诺·罗斯福（Franklin Delano Roosevelt）索要10美元，他后来竟然是——
Fidel Castro. Fidel Castro!
菲德尔·卡斯特罗（Fidel Castro）。菲德尔·卡斯特罗！
Fidel Castro is actually unusual. Most of the rest of the story episodes are about white guys. We sent away for this MP3 archive of 663 episodes. 34 were women.
菲德尔·卡斯特罗的情况确实不寻常。《故事的余韵》大部分剧集讲的都是白人男性的故事。我们订购了一份包含663集节目的MP3档案。其中女性只有34集。
Sometimes Paul Harvey would go historical, like when he tells the story of a practice that was banned in England and colonial America because it led to disorder in the streets, unruly mobs spilling into churches, profanity. But people would not stop doing this thing. It went underground and continues to this day.
有时保罗·哈维会讲历史，比如当他讲述一种在英国和殖民地时期的美国被禁止的做法时，因为这种做法会导致街头混乱、不守规矩的暴民涌入教堂、亵渎神明。但人们就是无法停止做这件事。它转入地下，并一直持续到今天。
Americans simply could not, still cannot kick the habit of it, of observing Christmas.
美国人根本无法、也仍然无法戒掉这种习惯，那就是庆祝圣诞节的习惯。
I went back and listened to a bunch of these in preparing this week's show. And I've wondered if you could tell the story of The Rest of the Story in the style of The Rest of the Story. OK, here's my best shot at that.
在准备本周节目时，我回去听了好多集。我一直在想，你是否能以《故事的余韵》的风格来讲述《故事的余韵》这个节目的故事？好吧，这是我最好的尝试。
Mr. Aurandt was 28 years old-- a concert pianist, doing great, performed with orchestras all over the world. But then he decided to make a change, something that would be less nerve-racking than waking up to perform. His new gig? Writing radio scripts, five a week, for somebody else to read. They made thousands this way together.
奥兰特先生（Mr. Aurandt）当时28岁——他是一位音乐会钢琴家，事业蒸蒸日上，与世界各地的管弦乐队合作演出。但后来他决定做出改变，去做一件比每天醒来就去演出压力小得多的事。他的新工作？为别人写广播稿，每周写五篇。他们通过这种方式一起赚了成千上万。
The guy on the radio got all the credit. People thought of it as his show. The person who got all the credit was Paul Harvey. Mr. Aurandt was in the background. And who was Mr. Aurandt? Well, I should tell you his full name-- Paul Aurandt, Jr.
广播里的人获得了所有的赞誉。人们认为这是他的节目。获得所有赞誉的人是保罗·哈维。奥兰特先生则在幕后。那么奥兰特先生是谁呢？好吧，我应该告诉你他的全名——小保罗·奥兰特（Paul Aurandt, Jr.）。
His father? Well, some people once knew him as Paul Aurandt, but you know him by a different name-- Paul Harvey. That's right. Every episode of the rest of the story was written for Paul Harvey by his own son. And now you know the rest of the story.
他的父亲？好吧，有些人曾经认识他叫保罗·奥兰特，但你用另一个名字认识他——保罗·哈维。没错。每一集《故事的余韵》都是他自己的儿子为保罗·哈维写的。现在，你知道了故事的余韵。
What's so enjoyable about these stories is they just put you into this world where it seems like, OK, everything is going one way, and then there's a twist at the end that changes everything. It all looks different. And here at our show this week, we thought, we wanna do that. That seems fun.
这些故事最令人愉悦的地方在于，它们把你带入这样一个世界：一切似乎都朝一个方向发展，然后在结尾处出现一个转折，改变了一切。一切看起来都不同了。本周我们的节目也想尝试这样做。那看起来很有趣。
So today, we have three real-life stories where things are going along one path, and then things turn, and the meaning of everything changes. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
所以今天，我们准备了三个真实的故事，事情最初沿着一条路径发展，然后发生了转折，一切的意义都改变了。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act one, "Burning Down the Couch." OK, so at any point in the last four decades if you've felt depressed or anxious, or for any other reason you decided to see a psychiatrist, there's a Rest of the Story story behind the treatment they offer. It's the story of a man named Ray Osheroff. He was a psychiatry patient in 1979 whose case was part of turning the entire field of psychiatry into what it is today. He became famous, or maybe I should say notorious, among psychiatrists.
第一幕，“烧掉沙发”。好吧，在过去四十年里的任何时候，如果你感到抑郁或焦虑，或者因为任何其他原因决定去看精神科医生，他们所提供的治疗背后其实都有一个《故事的余韵》。这是一个名叫雷·奥舍罗夫（Ray Osheroff）的人的故事。他是1979年的一名精神科病人，他的病例是让整个精神病学领域变成今天样子的重要部分。他在精神科医生中变得出名，或者我应该说声名狼藉。
Ray died over a decade ago, but one of our producers, Chris Benderev, has been digging into what happened. Here he is.
雷在十多年前去世了，但我们的制片人之一克里斯·本德雷夫（Chris Benderev）一直在深入挖掘所发生的一切。他在下面。
Let's begin with how a lot of psychiatrists would tell you the story of Ray Osheroff. It starts in the mid-1970s when life was good for Ray. He was a doctor, a kidney doctor, with a successful pair of dialysis clinics in the DC area. He lived in a gorgeous house in a swanky part of northern Virginia with his new wife. They had a baby on the way.
让我们从许多精神科医生会如何讲述雷·奥舍罗夫的故事开始。故事始于20世纪70年代中期，那时雷的生活很美好。他是一名医生，一名肾脏科医生，在华盛顿特区地区拥有两家成功的透析诊所。他和新婚妻子住在北弗吉尼亚州高档社区的一座华丽房子里。他们即将迎来一个孩子。
But then he descended into what we'd call today a mental health crisis. What set this off were two decisions Ray made. First, Ray sold off his ownership stake in his clinics. He'd continue to be the top doctor there, but he didn't want the stress of running them anymore.
但随后他陷入了我们今天所说的心理健康危机。导致这一切发生的是雷做出的两个决定。首先，雷卖掉了他在诊所的所有权股份。他继续担任那里的顶级医生，但他不想再承受经营诊所的压力了。
And second, Ray had an ex-wife. And this ex-wife asked him if she could take their two boys to Europe for a year. Her new husband's job was sending him there. And Ray said OK. But Ray came to regret both decisions, felt he'd thrown away his business and felt he'd abandoned his two boys. He spiraled into a deep depression.
其次，雷有一位前妻。这位前妻问他是否可以带他们的两个儿子去欧洲待一年。她新丈夫的工作要把他调到那里。雷同意了。但雷开始后悔这两个决定，觉得他丢掉了自己的事业，觉得他抛弃了两个儿子。他陷入了深深的抑郁之中。
He becomes increasingly repetitive almost. It was like he was stuck in these thought loops.
他变得越来越重复，几乎到了某种程度。就好像他被困在了这些思维循环中。
This is Rachel Aviv. She's a staff writer for The New Yorker. There's a chapter in her latest book about Ray.
这是雷切尔·阿维夫（Rachel Aviv）。她是《纽约客》（The New Yorker）的特约撰稿人。她最新的一本书中有一个章节是关于雷的。
And he couldn't stop replaying all of his missteps. And that led him to a state of feeling suicidal, and his wife felt like he needed to be hospitalized.
他无法停止重温他所有的失误。这导致他处于一种想要自杀的状态，他的妻子觉得他需要住院治疗。
Ray picked one of the most esteemed psychiatric hospitals in the country, Chestnut Lodge in Rockville, Maryland. Ray didn't know much about the Lodge. But he'd heard of it because it'd became famous as the basis of a best-selling novel called I Never Promised You a Rose Garden. The book uses different names for the main character and the location, but it basically tells the story of the author's own experience as a patient at Chestnut Lodge.
雷选择了该国最受尊敬的精神病院之一，马里兰州洛克维尔的栗树小屋（Chestnut Lodge）。雷对栗树小屋了解不多。但他听说过这个地方，因为它作为畅销小说《我从未向你许诺玫瑰园》（I Never Promised You a Rose Garden）的基础而闻名。这本书对主角和地点使用了不同的名字，但基本讲述了作者本人作为栗树小屋病人的经历。
It was about this young girl. And essentially, over the course of a year the most famous analyst there brings her from a state of psychosis to being almost entirely recovered.
那是关于一个小女孩的故事。本质上，在一年多的时间里，那里最著名的精神分析学家将她从精神错乱状态带到了几乎完全康复。
The Lodge believed you could fix even serious issues by taking time to really talk them out and dissect them.
栗树小屋相信，通过花时间真正地把问题说出来并进行剖析，即使是严重的问题也能解决。
Like you need to address whatever is causing your anguish. And through the patient listening of the analyst, you'll finally understand what is causing your illness.
就像你需要解决任何导致你痛苦的事情一样。通过精神分析学家耐心的倾听，你最终会理解是什么导致了你的疾病。
It's kind of a beautiful idea. It's like you take this respite to understand yourself.
这是一种很美好的想法。就像你通过这种喘息来了解自己。
Yeah, it felt like such a humane approach to mental illness and the spirit of optimism.
是的，这感觉像是一种对待精神疾病的人道方法，以及一种乐观的精神。
And on January 2, 1979, Ray is driven to Chestnut Lodge.
1979年1月2日，雷被送到了栗树小屋。
This is Eric Caplan, a historian of psychiatry who's writing a book about Ray. Eric says Ray checked himself into the Lodge expecting to be there two, maybe three months at the most. But winter turned to spring, and Ray was still inside. Eric spoke with a friend of Ray's who went to visit him around that time.
这是埃里克·卡普兰（Eric Caplan），一位正在写关于雷的书的精神病学历史学家。埃里克说，雷办理栗树小屋入住时，预计在那里住两三个月最多。但冬天转为春天，雷仍然待在里面。埃里克与雷的一位朋友交谈，他在那个时候去探望过他。
He told me Ray was this incredibly well-groomed person who only used to wear bespoke suits. And here he goes to see his friend, and he arrives, and he can't believe his eyes. Ray's hair is down to his shoulders. He's bedraggled. He's lost now 40 to 45 pounds. So none of his clothes fit. He can no longer use a fork and knife. His fine motor skills had deteriorated, so he would eat with his hands.
他告诉我，雷过去是一个非常讲究仪容的人，只穿定制西装。但他去见他的朋友时，雷到了，他简直不敢相信自己的眼睛。雷的头发长到了肩膀。他衣衫褴褛。体重减了40到45磅。所以他以前的衣服都不合身了。他已经无法使用刀叉。他的精细运动技能已经退化，所以他用手抓着吃饭。
Eating with his hands?
用手抓着吃？
Was eating with his hands.
确实是用手抓着吃。
Ray had lost his dexterity and so much weight because he was in a constant state of agitation, couldn't stop pacing around the ward, ruminating about his failures as a father and a businessman.
雷失去了灵活性，体重也减轻了这么多，因为他一直处于不断的焦虑状态，无法停止在病房里踱步，反复思考他作为父亲和商人的失败。
He would pace up to 10 hours a day, eight to 10 hours a day. So his feet became blistered and infected to the point that he needed now regular treatment from a podiatrist.
他每天踱步多达10个小时，8到10个小时。所以他的脚磨出了水泡并感染了，以至于他现在需要足病医生进行定期治疗。
Clearly, whatever they were doing at this premier psychiatric hospital was not working for Ray. And Chestnut Lodge's failure here is what this story is about, how professionals should treat mental illness. The Lodge believed fervently in old-fashioned psychoanalysis. They were fans of Sigmund Freud. When a patient arrived, they'd take an extremely detailed history. They interviewed Ray's mother extensively, learned about his tumultuous childhood, how his father mostly wasn't around, and how when he was he'd explode at Ray and belittle him mercilessly.
显然，他们在这家顶尖精神病院所做的任何事对雷都没有起作用。而栗树小屋在这里的失败正是这个故事的主题，关于专业人士应该如何治疗精神疾病。栗树小屋狂热地相信老派的精神分析。他们是西格蒙德·弗洛伊德（Sigmund Freud）的拥趸。当病人到达时，他们会进行极其详细的病史采集。他们对雷的母亲进行了深入采访，了解了他动荡的童年，他的父亲大多不在身边，以及当他在家时，他会如何对雷大发雷霆并无情地贬低他。
The Lodge believed so strongly in classical psychoanalysis that it usually wouldn't pair it with psychiatric medications. Whether a patient had depression or schizophrenia, the Lodge used drugs sparingly. So when Ray asked for antidepressants, which by 1979 would have been common in a psychiatric hospital--
栗树小屋对古典精神分析的信仰如此坚定，以至于它通常不会将其与精神科药物结合使用。无论病人患有抑郁症还是精神分裂症，栗树小屋都很少使用药物。所以当雷要求服用抗抑郁药时，这在1979年的精神病院里本应是很常见的——
They explained to him, no, we're not going to give you any drugs. And the direct quote that he's told by the ward administrator, a guy named Wesley Dingman, was, "You're going to need every neuron you have to fight this disease."
他们向他解释说，不，我们不会给你任何药物。病房管理员韦斯利·丁曼（Wesley Dingman）对他说过一句原话：“你需要利用你拥有的每一个神经元来对抗这种疾病。”
And so the Lodge continued with its treatment-- lots of psychoanalysis, no antidepressants. And Ray continued to unravel. Sometimes he'd hit himself. Other times, he'd pick fights with the other patients. And of course, he kept pacing. The Lodge did get Ray to calm down somewhat when they threatened to strap him down in ice-cold bed sheets for hours, something they were known to do with unruly patients.
于是栗树小屋继续它的治疗——大量的精神分析，没有抗抑郁药。而雷继续崩溃。有时他会打自己。其他时候，他会和其他病人打架。当然，他一直在踱步。当他们威胁要用冰冷的床单把他绑上几个小时时，栗树小屋确实让雷稍微冷静了一些，他们对不守规矩的病人通常会这样做。
In the Lodge's own internal notes, Ray's doctor admitted that Ray's symptoms weren't improving. But no matter. Their approach would be slow and steady. At one meeting, Ray's doctor said, quote, "If he does stay in treatment for five or 10 years, he may get a good result out of it." Another doctor said maybe Ray could switch to being an outpatient after three years. As best I can tell, the Lodge did not inform Ray about this timeline. Again, here's Rachel Aviv.
在栗树小屋自己的内部记录中，雷的医生承认雷的症状没有好转。但这没关系。他们的方法将是缓慢而稳定的。在一次会议上，雷的医生说：“如果他在治疗中待上五到十年，他可能会得到一个好的结果。”另一位医生说，也许雷可以在三年后转为门诊病人。据我所知，栗树小屋没有告知雷这个时间表。再次，这是雷切尔·阿维夫。
I think that is the assumption that's so insulting, that it's OK to just take a decade out of your life to be a patient who learns to understand yourself better.
我认为这种假设是非常侮辱人的，即认为拿出十年的生命去当一个学习更好地了解自己的病人是可以的。
Ray's mother, who was horrified at her son's deterioration inside the lodge, eventually checked Ray out and transferred him to a treatment center in Connecticut. There, he was finally prescribed antidepressants and other psychiatric medications. Once that happened, Ray's pacing lessened and eventually stopped altogether. By his 10th day, his depression and numbness began to lift. Here's an archival recording of Ray.
雷的母亲对儿子在小屋里的堕落感到惊恐，最终办理了出院手续，并将雷转到了康涅狄格州的一家治疗中心。在那里，他终于被开了抗抑郁药和其他精神科药物。一旦服药，雷的踱步减少了，最终完全停止了。到了第10天，他的抑郁和麻木感开始消退。这是雷的一段存档录音。
I think the first change I noticed in myself was that I could experience the feeling of sadness. What I had experienced before was different from sadness. And so one day when I woke up, I thought about, my God, I haven't seen my kids, oh, in a year, and then I started to weep. That is the first time I recall crying during that period of time.
我想我注意到的第一个变化是，我能体验到悲伤的感觉。我之前经历的与悲伤不同。所以有一天当我醒来时，我想，天哪，我已经有一年没见到我的孩子们了，然后我开始哭泣。这是我记得在那段时间里第一次哭泣。
There's a Jane Kenyon poem that describes when you take antidepressants, you suddenly feel like you've been forgiven for a crime that you realize you didn't commit. I think it is such a profound moment where all of these obsessive thoughts suddenly don't feel necessary anymore. There's just space in your brain. And that seems to be what happened for him.
简·肯扬（Jane Kenyon）有一首诗描述了当你服用抗抑郁药时，你突然感觉自己好像因为一个你意识到自己并没犯的罪行而得到了宽恕。我认为这是一个如此深刻的时刻，所有的这些强迫性念头突然不再感觉必要了。你的大脑里有了空间。这似乎就是发生在他身上的事情。
Within three months, Ray was back to his old self-- well groomed, cracking jokes. He went home to Virginia. But it had been almost a year, and a lot had changed.
三个月内，雷恢复了往常的样子——整洁、爱开玩笑。他回到了弗吉尼亚州的家中。但已经过去了快一年，很多事情都变了。
For one thing, Ray's ex-wife had gone to court to change their custody agreement. And because Ray was locked up at the Lodge, he'd lost his visitation rights with his kids. Meanwhile, Ray's new wife, who'd already moved out with the baby, was now divorcing him. And finally, when Ray returned to the dialysis practice that he'd helped build, the doctor he'd left in charge decided to open a competing office in the same building.
一方面，雷的前妻向法院申请更改了他们的监护协议。而且由于雷被关在小屋里，他失去了探望孩子的权利。与此同时，雷的新妻子已经带着孩子搬了出去，现在正在和他离婚。最后，当雷回到他帮忙建立的透析诊所时，他委托负责的那位医生决定在同一栋楼里开设一家竞争对手的诊所。
He felt like he had lost everything. He lost his children. He lost his wife. His house was empty because his wife had taken all the furniture. His patients followed this doctor to the new business, so he didn't have enough patients to fill a day of work.
他觉得他失去了一切。他失去了孩子。他失去了妻子。他的房子是空的，因为妻子拿走了所有的家具。他的病人跟随那位医生去了新公司，所以他没有足够的病人来填满一天的工作。
And now he knows because he went to two very different psychiatric hospitals that like, oh, maybe I could have just been gone for less than two months.
现在他知道了，因为他去了两家非常不同的精神病院，哦，也许我本可以不到两个月就出院的。
Yeah, exactly. And for him, that was infuriating.
是的，完全正确。对他来说，这令人愤怒。
And this is the part of the story that Ray's known for because he leapt into action to get back what he'd lost, like Uma Thurman in Kill Bill or Liam Neeson in Taken, if those revenge movies had taken place in Virginia and Maryland civil court proceedings. First, Ray petitioned to get back his visitation rights with his kids and got them. Then he sued his former colleague for undermining the business and won. And finally--
这就是雷出名的那部分故事，因为他采取了行动去夺回失去的一切，就像《杀死比尔》中的乌玛·瑟曼（Uma Thurman）或《飓风营救》中的连姆·尼森（Liam Neeson），如果那些复仇电影发生在弗吉尼亚州和马里兰州的民事法庭程序中的话。首先，雷申请夺回探望孩子的权利并成功了。然后他起诉了前同事破坏生意并胜诉了。最后——
This is the health claims arbitration case of Raphael J. Osheroff v. Chestnut Lodge et al.
这是拉斐尔·J·奥舍罗夫（Raphael J. Osheroff）诉栗树小屋等机构的医疗索赔仲裁案。
He sued Chestnut Lodge for malpractice. Ray's legal team argued that the Lodge had harmed him professionally and personally by withholding antidepressants and instead trying to break him down during countless therapy sessions. Here's one of Ray's lawyers describing how unusually harsh the Lodge doctors were.
他起诉栗树小屋医疗事故。雷的律师团队辩称，栗树小屋通过扣留抗抑郁药，并在无数次治疗中试图击垮他，在职业和个人方面对他造成了伤害。这是雷的一位律师描述小屋医生有多么异常严厉。
The therapy, you'll hear, was confrontative. And I'm quoting now. I'm not making this up.
你会听到，这种治疗具有对抗性。我现在引用一下。我不是编出来的。
"Cut the shit, Ray. You're symbolically dead. You'll disappear off the face of the earth. No one else wants to hear from you. The only person who feels guilty about what happened to you is your mother. The rest of the world could care less. Take a tin cup and go beg on Connecticut Avenue if things are so bad for you."
“别废话了，雷。你从象征意义上来说已经死了。你会从地球表面消失。没人在乎你说什么。唯一对发生在你身上的事感到愧疚的人是你母亲。世界上其他人根本不在乎。拿个锡杯去康涅狄格大道上乞讨吧，如果事情对你来说那么糟糕的话。”
Chestnut Lodge defended itself by saying they believed Ray's depression was secondary to deeper underlying issues which they had to fix first. The lawsuit dragged on for years. And as one professor put it, Ray's case was, quote, "discussed in every academic department of psychiatry in North America." Because on one side you had doctors like the ones at Chestnut Lodge. And on the other side, rooting for Ray, were a lot of psychiatrists who felt places like the Lodge had made their profession look reckless and out of touch, who worried their fellow doctors had basically forgotten the M in MD.
栗树小屋为自己辩护说，他们认为雷的抑郁症是更深层潜在问题的继发症状，他们必须先解决这些问题。诉讼持续了多年。正如一位教授所言，雷的案例“在北美每一个精神病学学术部门都被讨论过”。因为一方面你有像栗树小屋那样的医生。而另一方面，支持雷的是许多精神科医生，他们觉得像小屋这样的地方让他们的职业看起来鲁莽且脱节，他们担心他们的同行医生基本上忘记了医学博士（MD）中的M。
And in 1987, Chestnut Lodge settled and paid Ray an undisclosed amount of money. He later said it was around $350,000, nearly a million dollars in today's money. In essence, Ray won. Afterwards, psychiatrists everywhere were put on notice. Now, if they didn't at least offer medication when the evidence showed it could help, they might get sued too.
1987年，栗树小屋达成和解，并向雷支付了一笔未披露的金额。他后来说是大约35万美元，相当于今天近100万美元。本质上，雷赢了。之后，各地的精神科医生都被告知。现在，如果他们在证据表明药物可能有效时至少不提供药物，他们也可能被起诉。
Ray's case is not the only reason that when you walk into a psychiatrist's office today you are far more likely to be offered pills than a Rorschach test, but it contributed to that shift. In the late '80s and early '90s, Ray's case was written about in big academic journals. He spoke at psychiatry's biggest annual conference. The Philadelphia Inquirer and The New York Times wrote about the case.
雷的案例并不是今天你走进精神科诊所时更有可能被提供药片而不是罗夏测试的唯一原因，但它促成了这种转变。在80年代末和90年代初，雷的案例在大型学术期刊上被报道。他在精神病学最大的年度会议上发言。《费城问询报》（The Philadelphia Inquirer）和《纽约时报》（The New York Times）都报道了这个案例。
Then in 1989, The Washington Post wrote a long feature about Chestnut Lodge and Ray. It ended by saying he'd found love again and reestablished relationships with his three sons. The reporter wrote that Ray, quote, "feels lucky that he's been able to work his way back to normalcy." And Ray basically became lore.
1989年，《华盛顿邮报》（The Washington Post）写了一篇关于栗树小屋和雷的长篇特写。结尾说他再次找到了真爱，并与三个儿子重建了关系。记者写道，雷“感到幸运的是，他能够通过努力回到正常状态”。雷基本上成为了一个传说。
The way that I confronted the story, like in textbooks-- I had read an obituary of him in 2012, was he won this case. It represented the triumph of biological psychiatry. We can no longer deprive people of medications they need. And he lived happily ever after. And that's pretty much where the story ends. But that's just not what happened.
我接触这个故事的方式，比如在教科书中——我在2012年读过他的讣告，是他赢得了这场官司。它代表了生物精神病学的胜利。我们不能再剥夺人们所需的药物。从此他过上了幸福的生活。故事到这里基本就结束了。但那根本不是发生的事情。
The truth is it was not happily ever after. The simple story that the meds made him better, it wasn't that simple. Here's the rest of the story.
事实并非从此幸福生活。关于药物让他变好的简单故事，并没有那么简单。这就是故事的余韵。
By the time Ray died in 2012, in terms of family at least, Ray was largely alone. He'd been divorced four times, and he'd been estranged from all three of his children. So what happened? What went wrong?
到雷在2012年去世时，至少在家庭方面，雷基本上是孤独的。他离过四次婚，并与三个孩子中的所有人都疏远了。那么发生了什么？出了什么问题？
Obviously, I couldn't ask Ray directly. But in a memoir he later wrote, he made it pretty clear who he thought was responsible-- Chestnut Lodge. Quote, "By destroying every facet of my personhood, they deprived me forever of love and any possible measure of security and satisfaction that I could ever gain thereafter. They amputated my past, deprived me of a future."
显然，我无法直接问雷。但在他后来写的回忆录中，他明确说明了他认为谁该负责——栗树小屋。“通过摧毁我人格的每一个方面，他们永远剥夺了我的爱以及我此后可能获得的任何安全感和满足感。他们切断了我的过去，剥夺了我的未来。”
In that memoir, which was never published, Ray writes that he'd had an idyllic relationship with his sons. They'd bond during car rides. He'd give them baths and gently tuck them into bed at night.
在那本从未出版的回忆录中，雷写道，他曾与儿子们有着田园诗般的关系。他们会在车里建立联系。他会给他们洗澡，晚上温柔地把他们塞进被窝。
Then came the move to Europe, his depression, and, most importantly, Chestnut Lodge. After all that, he wrote, it was too late to salvage a relationship. The thing is, Ray's kids don't see it that way. Here's Sam Osheroff, Ray's oldest son.
然后是搬到欧洲，他的抑郁症，以及最重要的一点，栗树小屋。在所有这些之后，他写道，挽救关系已经太晚了。问题是，雷的孩子们并不这么看。这是萨姆·奥舍罗夫（Sam Osheroff），雷的长子。
So I think there are two truths. I think he was maltreated at Chestnut Lodge. I think he should have sued. I think what happened to him was a tragedy. Yeah. And he did lose things to that. But I would say that even if my father had never gone through that acute depression and went into Chestnut Lodge, he still would have been in the same position at the end of his life.
所以我认为有两个真相。我认为他在栗树小屋受到了虐待。我认为他应该起诉。我认为发生在他身上的是一场悲剧。是的。他确实因此失去了一些东西。但我要说，即使我父亲从未经历过那次严重的抑郁症并进入栗树小屋，他在生命结束时也会处于同样的境地。
Sam says his dad wound up cut off from so much of the family because of problems with his behavior that predate his time at Chestnut Lodge and his spiral into depression, and even his kids moving to Europe. They were there from as early as Sam can remember.
萨姆说，他父亲最终与家人的大部分成员切断了联系，这是因为他在进入栗树小屋和陷入抑郁之前就存在的行为问题，甚至早于他的孩子们搬到欧洲之前。萨姆从有记忆开始，这些问题就存在了。
As a child, you don't know what that means to be mentally ill, but you can certainly sense it, yeah. And it pervaded everything.
作为一个孩子，你不知道精神疾病意味着什么，但你肯定能感觉到，是的。它渗透到了一切之中。
What do you mean by that, pervaded everything?
你说的渗透到一切之中是什么意思？
I think every interaction with him, every overnight visit, it was off. Everything was off. Things were weird and tense. And yeah, I don't remember ever a moment of relaxation with him. I think he carried around an enormous and unrelenting amount of rage with him at all times.
我想与他的每一次互动，每一次过夜探访，都是不对劲的。一切都不对劲。事情变得奇怪和紧张。是的，我不记得和他在一起有任何放松的时刻。我认为他一直带着一种巨大且无情的愤怒。
Was it scary? Like did you did you worry about him focusing it on you?
这吓人吗？比如你是否担心他会把怒气发泄在你身上？
Yeah. I never worried about him-- OK, here's an incident. I remember once we were spending the night at his house. And I had a friend spending the night. And as you do when you're eight, you stay up, and you laugh, and you read comic books.
是的。我从不担心他——好吧，有一件事。我记得有一次我们在他家过夜。我有个朋友也在过夜。就像你8岁时会做的那样，你们熬夜、大笑、读漫画书。
And he came in and started screaming at us to go to bed. And he opened the door and slammed it, and then opened it and slammed it, and opened it and slammed it. He must have done it 25 times. So that's the kind of rage. And yeah, that's, you know. I wouldn't say it was directed at me. I was the unlucky recipient for being in the wrong place at the wrong time and doing something innocuous that happened to set it off at that moment.
他进来开始尖叫着叫我们去睡觉。他打开门又猛地关上，然后又打开又猛地关上，如此反复。他一定做了25次。所以这就是那种愤怒。是的，那，你知道。我不会说那是针对我的。我只是因为在错误的时间出现在错误的地点，做了一件无伤大雅的事情，正好在那一刻触发了他的愤怒。
Sam and others say that Ray was always quick to anger and just aggressive. Sam's stepdad told me that Ray once threatened to have him killed by a hit man, said Ray told him he'd figured out exactly how much the job would cost. And the thing is, even after Ray got out of Chestnut Lodge, got on meds, won his visitation rights back, and became semi-famous for his miracle cure, his sons say that he kept doing the same kinds of disturbing things that he'd done before he'd been hospitalized.
萨姆和其他人说，雷总是容易发怒且好斗。萨姆的继父告诉我，雷曾经威胁要雇杀手杀他，说雷告诉他已经算好这份工作的成本。事实是，即使在雷离开栗树小屋、服用药物、赢回探视权并因他的“奇迹康复”而变得小有名气之后，他的儿子们说他仍然在做那些他在住院前做过的令人不安的事情。
Like this one time in 1987, Ray was trying to rebuild his relationship with Sam and his younger brother Joe. The boys had developed an interest in theater, so Ray took them to a show at the Kennedy Center in DC. Joe says his dad was sometimes really generous in that way.
比如有一次在1987年，雷正试图重建与萨姆和他弟弟乔（Joe）的关系。男孩们对戏剧产生了兴趣，所以雷带他们去华盛顿特区的肯尼迪中心看戏。乔说他父亲有时在那方面确实很大方。
But then during the show, Ray's beeper started going off over and over. Remember, he's a doctor. Multiple times, Ray got up, shuffled down the aisle, and took the calls. Here's Joe.
但在演出期间，雷的传呼机开始反复响个不停。记住，他是一名医生。雷多次站起来，在走道里磨蹭，接听电话。这是乔。
This thing was so loud, this beeper. It would reverberate off the walls. So at the end of the show, we're in a sea of audience members trying to leave the theater. And someone said, hey, next time, leave your beeper at home. And he said, lady, I hope your mother gets sick as shit someday and nobody comes to take care of her. And he didn't just say it under his breath. He was screaming it at her.
这个传呼机的声音太响了。它会在墙壁上回荡。所以演出结束时，我们在人群中试图离开剧院。有人说，嘿，下次把传呼机留在家里吧。他说，女士，我希望你妈哪天病得像屎一样，没人来照顾她。他不仅小声嘀咕，他是对着她尖叫。
What do you and Sam do during a moment like that?
在那样的时刻，你和萨姆做什么？
Oh, we walked 50 feet ahead of him all the way to the parking lot.
哦，我们一路跑在离他50英尺远的地方直到停车场。
Huh.
呵。
Even as I talk about it now, I get butterflies in my stomach.
即使我现在谈起它，我也感到胃里翻腾。
For his sons, Ray was still just as uncomfortable to live with as he had been before the Chestnut Lodge saga. They did notice one thing had changed about their dad though. He began talking often about how because of what he'd gone through at the Lodge, he was on his way to becoming a household name.
对他的儿子们来说，雷仍然像栗树小屋事件之前一样让他们难以忍受。不过他们确实注意到父亲的一件事变了。他开始经常谈论因为他在小屋的经历，他正在成为家喻户晓的名字。
He would hint. He'd say, this incredible thing happened to me. You wouldn't believe it. I'm writing a book. It's going to be a movie. I've talked to these producers. It's going to be the biggest movie of the year.
他会暗示。他会说，我身上发生了这件不可思议的事情。你不会相信的。我正在写一本书。这会是一部电影。我和这些制片人谈过。这将是年度最大的电影。
Ray gave Sam and Joe the latest draft of his memoir. As time went on, their relationship with their dad became more strained. And they say Ray started directing more of his anger at them. For Sam, this all came to a head a bit after he'd graduated from college.
雷把他的回忆录最新草稿给了萨姆和乔。随着时间的推移，他们与父亲的关系变得更加紧张。他们说雷开始把更多的愤怒指向他们。对于萨姆来说，这一切在大学毕业后的一段时间里爆发了。
He actually stood up in the middle of a restaurant and began screaming at me. And at that point, I walked out of the restaurant. And I had no idea where I was. I don't think I had more than $5 on me at the time. And eventually found my way to some relative's house, spent the night there. The next morning, rented a car, drove home, and I did not see him again for many, many years.
他竟然在餐馆中间站起来开始对我尖叫。在那一刻，我走出了餐馆。我不知道我在哪里。当时我身上大概连5美元都没有。最终我找到了某个亲戚的家，在那里过了一夜。第二天早上，我租了一辆车，开车回家，从那以后很多很多年我都没见过他。
Joe cut off contact with Ray around the same time. Joe and Sam say Ray's third son, who they haven't heard from in 30 years, cut off contact with their dad even earlier. I reached out to him, but did not hear back.
乔在大约同一时间断绝了与雷的联系。乔和萨姆说，他们的第三个兄弟，他们已经30年没听过他的消息了，甚至更早就断绝了与父亲的联系。我联系了他，但没有收到回复。
These parts of Ray's personality that persisted after getting out of Chestnut Lodge and getting on meds, they actually came up in the lawsuit because the Lodge had a theory to explain them.
雷在离开栗树小屋并服用药物后仍然存在的这些性格部分，在诉讼中被提到了，因为小屋对此有一个解释理论。
Can you explain what is meant in psychiatry as the narcissistic personality?
你能解释一下精神病学中所谓的人格障碍是指什么吗？
Features will include grandiosity, absorption with self, shallow, brittle relationships with other human beings, and very--
特征包括自大、自我沉溺、与他人建立浅薄而脆弱的关系，以及非常——
This is Ray's former doctor at the Lodge, Manuel Ross.
这是雷在小屋的前医生曼努埃尔·罗斯（Manuel Ross）。
Those features would define a narcissistic personality disorder.
这些特征将定义为自恋型人格障碍。
Did you arrive at an opinion as to whether that was involved with Dr. Osheroff?
你是否对奥舍罗夫医生是否患有这种疾病得出了结论？
Yes, I thought there was no doubt about it.
是的，我认为毫无疑问。
Now, I should say over a dozen psychiatrists were deposed for the lawsuit. And there was disagreement over whether Ray would have met the clinical criteria for narcissistic personality disorder when he was at the Lodge. Some said no. Some weren't sure. Some thought he had some kind of personality disorder. Some said the depression made it hard to tell. But some, like Dr. Ross, were sure.
现在，我应该说，十几位精神科医生在诉讼中作了证。关于雷在小屋时是否符合自恋型人格障碍的临床标准，存在分歧。有些人说没有。有些人不确定。有些人认为他患有某种人格障碍。有些人说抑郁症让人很难判断。但有些人，像罗斯医生，很确定。
I felt that the narcissistic personality disorder had been an enduring feature of his life that had dogged him, that led to repeated difficulties with people in his life and essentially compromised his ability to lead a successful and rewarding existence.
我觉得自恋型人格障碍一直是他生命中一个持久的特征，一直困扰着他，导致他与生活中人的关系反复出现困难，并基本上损害了他过上成功和充实生活的能力。
Was Dr. Ross' diagnosis correct? I've tried to answer that question definitively, and I'm still not sure. But for whatever it's worth, I did read Ray's memoir, and here's what I can say.
罗斯医生的诊断正确吗？我试图明确回答这个问题，我仍然不确定。但无论如何，我确实读了雷的回忆录，这是我可以说的。
It does not read like a memoir. It reads like a disorganized, 500-page screed against a lot of the people he worked and lived with. He retraces his downfall over and over, each time with new conspirators working against him. And the tone is grandiose.
它读起来不像回忆录。它读起来像是一篇混乱的、500页的、针对他工作和生活过的许多人的长篇大论。他一次又一次地回顾他的堕落，每一次都有新的阴谋者在阻挠他。语气是自大的。
Ray writes unironically that he'd been a, quote, "king on a very shaky throne," whose success had drawn a host of predators. He'd been duped by, in his words, "vengeful wives" who'd introduced "avowed enemies" and "Trojan horses" into his dialysis practice in order to destroy it. Ray also rails against the lawyer who won him his settlement money against Chestnut Lodge because Ray felt he deserved millions more. In the book, Ray's greatest ire is saved for Chestnut Lodge though, who subjected him to a, quote, "one-man holocaust."
雷毫无讽刺意味地写道，他曾是“摇摇欲坠王座上的国王”，其成功吸引了一群掠夺者。他被他所谓“复仇的妻子”欺骗，她们引入了“公开的敌人”和“特洛伊木马”到他的透析诊所，目的是摧毁它。雷还抨击了那位为他赢得对阵栗树小屋和解金的律师，因为雷觉得他理应得到更多。但在书中，雷最大的愤怒还是留给了栗树小屋，他们让他遭受了所谓的“一人大屠杀”。
In 2010, Ray reached out to Sam on Facebook after years apart. He wanted to meet up. Sam's first child had just been born.
2010年，雷在分开多年后在Facebook上联系了萨姆。他想见面。萨姆的第一个孩子刚出生。
And I thought, well, this will be interesting. Maybe this will be a chance to introduce him to his granddaughter and perhaps we'll find some sort of way to move forward here. So we decided to meet in a town about 45 minutes away. And I remember it was a restaurant, and we were outdoors. So we must have been outside at a picnic table.
我想，好吧，这会很有趣。也许这是一个向他介绍他孙女的机会，也许我们会找到某种前进的方法。所以我们决定在一个离我家大约45分钟路程的小镇见面。我记得那是一家餐馆，我们在户外。所以我们一定是在外面的野餐桌旁。
Sam says his dad looked older and seemed gentler. He didn't raise his voice at all. But once they got their food--
萨姆说他父亲看起来老了些，显得更温柔。他一点也没提高嗓门。但一旦他们拿到食物——
It was like no time had passed. He picked up exactly where he left off. He was, again, obsessed with the Chestnut Lodge thing, obsessed with his book. And that's all he really wanted to talk about. He didn't really ask questions about my life, didn't really ask about his new granddaughter, just launched right back into the same old stuff as if we hadn't missed a decade together.
就像时间停止了。他又回到了原点。他再次沉迷于栗树小屋的事情，沉迷于他的书。这就是他真正想谈的一切。他并没有真的问关于我生活的问题，也没真的问关于他新孙女的事，只是直接回到了那套老词，就好像我们之间没有错过十年一样。
And when he see-- I mean, this is his granddaughter. How does he react when he sees her?
当你——我是说，这是他的孙女。他看到她时反应如何？
Well, I think he was happy to meet her, and he cooed over her a bit, but then pretty much directly afterwards went straight back into his spiel. You won't believe this. You have to read the new version of it. It's going to be a movie. And I know the rest of the however many hours we spent together was spent with him talking about himself and his Chestnut Lodge experience, and his book. And this is, what, 30, 35 years after the fact.
嗯，我想他很高兴见到她，他对着她咕咕地叫了一阵，但几乎紧接着就回到了他的老套路。你不会相信的。你必须读读它的新版本。它要拍成电影了。我知道我们在一起度过的剩下几个小时都是他在谈论他自己和他的栗树小屋经历，还有他的书。这是在事情发生30、35年之后。
I mean, you told me he handed you a copy of his manuscript of his book when you were a teenager, and he's basically doing the same thing again.
我的意思是，你告诉我他在你十几岁时给了你一份手稿副本，他基本上又在做同样的事情。
He brought another copy and gave me another copy.
他又带了一份副本，给了我一份副本。
He brought a copy of the book?
他带了一本书的副本？
Yep.
是的。
And it sounds like you did go in hoping maybe it'd be different.
听起来你确实是带着希望也许情况会有所不同去的。
Yeah. I mean, I think you always have that hope with a living parent until you can't anymore, that there can be some sort of way to salvage some part of a relationship. So it was pretty disappointing.
是的。我的意思是，我认为只要父母还在世，你总会有那种希望，直到你无法再有为止，即也许还有某种方式可以挽救关系的一部分。所以这相当令人失望。
I want to clarify that not everyone experienced Ray this way. For instance, a couple long-time friends of Ray's told me that he was definitely not a narcissist devoid of empathy. For one thing, as a doctor he cared deeply about his patients, sometimes helped pay their rent or fund funerals. And one of Ray's friends told me he was a good listener, someone that she could vent to for an hour uninterrupted. This friend believed Ray had other kinds of mental disorders though and admitted that he could get, quote, "obsessional," especially about the Chestnut Lodge ordeal, which colored the rest of his life. He was a great friend, she said, but probably somebody who was very difficult to live with.
我想澄清的是，并非每个人对雷的感受都是这样的。例如，雷的几位老朋友告诉我，他绝不是一个缺乏同理心的自恋者。一方面，作为一名医生，他非常关心他的病人，有时帮助支付他们的房租或资助葬礼。雷的一位朋友告诉我，他是一个很好的倾听者，一个她可以连续倾诉一小时而不被中断的人。这位朋友认为雷患有其他类型的精神障碍，但也承认他可能会变得“强迫性”，特别是在栗树小屋的磨难上，这影响了他的余生。她说，他是一个很棒的朋友，但可能是一个非常难以相处的人。
Whatever ailed him, Ray did seem to know that there was something wrong with him. All his life, he kept receiving psychotherapy and various medications. He even did electroshock therapy. But it never seemed to help with his closest relationships. I put all this to Rachel Aviv.
无论他有什么病，雷似乎确实知道自己出了问题。他一生都在接受心理治疗和各种药物治疗。他甚至做了电休克疗法。但它似乎从未帮助他处理最亲密的关系。我把这一切告诉了雷切尔·阿维夫。
Reading about Ray and learning about Ray, he does make me think of certain people I know. And I think maybe we all know people like this who are just difficult. And it's just like they can't seem to change. And I don't know. I find myself interested in that because I don't know what they're supposed to do or what we're supposed to do if they're kind of truly unchangeable.
阅读关于雷的事，了解关于雷的事，他确实让我想起了一些我认识的人。我想也许我们都认识这样的人，他们只是很麻烦。就好像他们似乎无法改变。我不知道。我发现自己对这一点很感兴趣，因为我不知道如果他们是真的无法改变，他们该做什么，或者我们该做什么。
Yeah, I think everyone knows someone a little bit like him. And I think the really hard thing is that there isn't actually a good cure for that.
是的，我想每个人都认识一点像他这样的人。我认为最难的事情是，实际上并没有好的治疗方法。
Right. There isn't a pill that we give for that.
没错。我们没有给那种情况的药片。
No. And that feels like a challenge to the project of psychiatry, that there are people who have personality problems, but that are not that receptive to treatment.
没有。这感觉像是对精神病学项目的挑战，有些人有人格问题，但对治疗并不那么接受。
If Ray did have a personality disorder, it's worth noting that they are, as the American Psychological Association put it, notoriously hard to treat. It's funny. The story that Ray's best known for is a hopeful one. The moral is meds can help us. Psychiatry can help us.
如果雷确实患有人格障碍，值得注意的是，正如美国心理学协会所言，它们以难以治疗而闻名。很有趣。雷最出名的故事是一个充满希望的故事。寓意是药物可以帮助我们。精神病学可以帮助我们。
But when you look at the whole arc of Ray's life and see what his family saw, and how he ended up, that story falls apart. Yes, meds can help. But if anything, Ray's life shows the limits of what psychiatry can do for us, how some of us have problems that psychiatry still has a hard time defining and an even harder time trying to fix.
但当你审视雷的一生的整个历程，看到他的家人所看到的，以及他最终的结局，那个故事就瓦解了。是的，药物可以帮助。但如果说有什么的话，雷的一生展现了精神病学能为我们做的极限，有些人有一些精神病学仍然很难定义，甚至更难修复的问题。
Chris Benderev is a producer on our show. Rachel Aviv's book that features a chapter on Ray is called Strangers to Ourselves. Eric Caplan is looking for a publisher for his book about Ray's case. It's called Do No Harm.
克里斯·本德雷夫是我们节目的制片人。雷切尔·阿维夫关于雷的章节的书名叫《我们自己的陌生人》（Strangers to Ourselves）。埃里克·卡普兰正在为他关于雷案例的书寻找出版商。书名叫《勿伤害》（Do No Harm）。
Coming up, you get to a certain age with your parents and what could they ever do to surprise you? What cards could they still hold up their sleeve? One man finds out in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，当你和父母到了一定年龄，他们还能做什么让你吃惊的事？他们的袖子里还能藏着什么牌？一个人在芝加哥公共广播电台节目继续时将在一分钟内发现。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, "The Rest of the Story." I loved Paul Harvey's old radio show, which had that name, and we are shamelessly knocking it off today. We have stories where things seem to be all heading one way, meaning one thing, and then there's a twist.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是《故事的余韵》。我喜欢保罗·哈维的那个老广播节目，它有这个名字，我们今天无耻地模仿了它。我们讲述的故事似乎都朝一个方向发展，意味着一件事，然后出现了一个转折。
We have arrived at act two of our program. Act two, "Oh, Mother, Where Art Thou?" Samuel James has actually lived through a rest of the story kind of experience in his own life. Here he is.
我们已经进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，“哦，母亲，你在哪里？”（Oh, Mother, Where Art Thou?）塞缪尔·詹姆斯（Samuel James）在他自己的生活中确实经历过一种《故事的余韵》式的体验。他在下面。
My mother died three times, each more surprising than the last. The first time she died, I was 12 years old. No one wants to tell a child their mother is dead, let alone how it happened. I was also in foster homes at the time, and I was told about her death in the shortest, most emotionally convenient way possible for them. "Your mother took prescription pills," they said. "It says on the bottle not to take pills with alcohol, but she did."
我母亲死过三次，每一次都比上一次更令人惊讶。她第一次死时，我12岁。没人想告诉孩子他们的母亲死了，更不用说它是怎么发生的。我当时还在寄养家庭，他们以尽可能简短、情感上最方便的方式告诉了我她的死讯。“你母亲吃了处方药，”他们说。“瓶子上写着不要和酒精一起服用，但她喝了。”
And so I decided to never drink alcohol. It's an easy decision for a 12-year-old, and somehow it never got any more difficult. Peer pressure only made me dig in harder.
所以我决定永远不喝酒。对于一个12岁的孩子来说，这是一个容易的决定，不知何故它从未变得更困难。同龄人的压力只会让我更加坚定。
My parents had been together for more than 20 years when my mother died. Mourning was especially difficult for my father. But time healed as many wounds as it could. Surviving became managing became thriving.
我父母在我母亲去世时已经在一起超过20年了。对于我父亲来说，哀悼尤其困难。但时间治愈了它能治愈的伤口。生存变成了管理，变成了繁荣。
He developed a relationship with her memory. And anyone who came to the house would have to join in because he'd put the brass urn containing my mother's ashes on top of the entertainment center right above the TV, like a shrine. Sometimes there was incense beside it. Sometimes the urn was in a blue velvet bag. Sometimes it was just there by itself.
他与她的记忆建立了一种关系。任何来家里的人都必须加入，因为他会把装有我母亲骨灰的黄铜骨灰瓮放在娱乐中心的电视上方，就像神龛一样。有时旁边有熏香。有时骨灰瓮在天鹅绒蓝袋子里。有时它只是在那儿。
One day-- I was an adult at this point-- my father and I were watching TV together. My eyes drifted up to my mother's urn, and I started thinking back to being told how she died. I learned years earlier that the pills she'd taken with alcohol were for bipolar disorder. As an adult, I've seen what that can be like. And so as we were sitting there, I just started thinking out loud.
有一天——我此时已经是成年人了——我和父亲一起看电视。我的目光飘向了母亲的骨灰瓮，我开始回想被告知她是如何去世的。我几年前才知道她和酒精一起服用的药是治疗双相情感障碍的。作为成年人，我见过那会是什么样。所以当我们坐在那里时，我只是开始大声思考。
"You know," I said, "I always thought there was a chance that Mom took her own life." "What?" my father replied, confused. "I don't know," I said. "I've known some people over the years who also suffer with bipolar disorder. I thought there was a chance."
“你知道，”我说，“我一直认为有可能妈妈是自杀的。”“什么？”我父亲回答，很困惑。“我不知道，”我说。“多年来我认识一些也患有双相情感障碍的人。我想有可能。”
My father asked, "Wait. What the hell are you talking about?" "I just thought there was a chance she committed suicide. We don't have to talk about it. I'm not trying to start a fight." My father, more confused than ever and more than a little annoyed, "Of course she committed suicide!"
我父亲问：“等等。你在说什么鬼话？”“我只是觉得有可能她是自杀的。我们不必谈论它。我不是想吵架。”我父亲比以往任何时候都更困惑，甚至有点恼火：“她当然是自杀的！”
She had died from taking pills with alcohol, like my caseworker told me at the time, leaving out one very important part. It's not as though my father and I never talked about my mother. We talked about her all the time, just never about the circumstances of her death. We'd both avoided the topic out of respect for each other, similarly and mistakenly thinking we had a common understanding. This was the second time my mother died.
她死于服用药物加酒精，就像我当时的个案工作者告诉我的那样，漏掉了一个非常重要的部分。并不是我和我父亲从未谈论过我母亲。我们一直在谈论她，只是从没谈过她死时的具体情况。我们出于对彼此的尊重都避开了这个话题，同样地、错误地认为我们有一个共同的理解。这是我母亲第二次死。
We talked for a long time, both incredulous. The light and funny mood of our usual conversations came and went, going through the details, wondering how we'd both missed this for decades. To me, his life as a widower was suddenly so much heavier than I'd realized. He was suddenly so much stronger than I'd realized. And I became aware of a war inside my mother that I'd never realized.
我们谈了很长时间，都表示难以置信。我们通常谈话中轻松有趣的氛围来来去去，详细梳理细节，纳闷我们怎么都忽略了这一点几十年。对我来说，他作为鳏夫的生活突然比我意识到的要沉重得多。他突然比我意识到的要强大得多。而我意识到母亲内心有一场我从未察觉的战争。
Learning how your parent died decades later, you feel like you're supposed to do something with that, but you don't know what. There's a remourning, and certain memories begin to look very different. The main reason I'm a musician is because of my parents' love of music, my mother especially. She was a trained dancer from a young age, and so I was taking dance lessons at age five.
几十年后才了解你父母是如何去世的，你会觉得你应该对此做点什么，但你不知道做什么。有一种重新哀悼，某些记忆开始看起来非常不同。我成为音乐家的主要原因是我父母对音乐的热爱，尤其是母亲。她从小就是受过训练的舞者，所以我5岁时就开始上舞蹈课。
Dance parties would spring up in the house all the time, and I loved joining the old people doing the old dances, even though they sometimes came with unnecessary tutorials. I remember a long lecture once on the difference between the Twist and the Peppermint Twist. Dancing in the house was normalized to the point that I've had dance parties throughout my life even now.
家里经常会出现舞会，我喜欢加入那些跳老式舞蹈的老人们，尽管他们有时会附带不必要的教程。我记得有一次关于扭扭舞（Twist）和薄荷扭扭舞（Peppermint Twist）之间区别的长篇讲座。在家跳舞已经常态化了，甚至现在我一生中也一直举行舞会。
But what I didn't see at the time was how manic my mother's dance parties were. I didn't notice that sometimes they lasted so long my parents weren't able to do that day's errands. Sometimes the dance parties happened instead of important appointments. I never noticed how tired all of this made my father. I did notice that the dance parties didn't happen when she got sad.
但我当时没看到的是我母亲的舞会是多么狂躁。我没注意到有时它们持续太久以至于我父母无法完成当天的琐事。有时舞会代替了重要的预约。我从未注意到这一切让我父亲有多累。我确实注意到当她变伤心时，舞会就不会发生。
But not everything shifted. Some memories didn't change at all. By the time I was five years old, I asked my mother for a drum kit, and she says yes. And a few months go by, and I ask her if she wants to hear me play Gene Krupa's legendary drum solo from "Sing, Sing, Sing." And she says yes.
但并非一切都改变了。有些记忆一点也没变。在我5岁时，我问母亲要一套鼓，她说好。几个月过去了，我问她是否想听我演奏吉恩·克鲁帕（Gene Krupa）在《Sing, Sing, Sing》中传奇的鼓独奏。她说好。
I started playing music at five, but I'm not a prodigy by any means. I'm a regular five-year-old kid thrashing around on the drums, and I can't keep a beat. And so I finished playing this solo terribly. And she applauds. And I ask if she wants to hear it again. And she says yes. So I play it again.
我5岁开始演奏音乐，但我绝不是神童。我只是一个普通的5岁小孩在鼓上乱敲，我跟不上节奏。所以我把这个独奏演奏得非常糟糕。她鼓掌。我问她是否想再听一遍。她说好。所以我又演奏了一遍。
I was too tired to try a third time, but if I had asked she would have said yes again. She would have said yes all day. There's no mania in that, just love.
我太累了没法尝试第三遍，但如果我问了，她肯定会再说好。她会说好一整天。那里面没有狂躁，只有爱。
My father's will stated his wish to be cremated. He wanted his ashes buried at the veterans' cemetery about an hour from my home, and he wanted my mother's ashes to be mixed in with his. I had him cremated, but I stopped his wishes there. Putting his ashes that far from me felt like throwing him away, so I kept him at my apartment.
我父亲的遗嘱写明了他希望被火葬的愿望。他希望他的骨灰埋在离我家大约一小时路程的退伍军人公墓，他希望我母亲的骨灰和他混在一起。我把他火化了，但我没有实现他的遗愿。把他的骨灰放得离我那么远感觉像是抛弃了他，所以我把他留在了我的公寓里。
But shortly after my father died, I spoke to his friend, Fred, who I've never liked. He asked me about my father's ashes and when they might be at the cemetery. I had told them I was figuring that out, but all the figuring had been done. My father was where he was going to stay.
但在我父亲去世后不久，我与他的朋友弗雷德（Fred）谈过，我一直不喜欢他。他问我关于我父亲骨灰的事，以及它们什么时候会去墓地。我告诉他们我正在考虑，但所有的考虑都已经做完了。我父亲就在他要待的地方。
But then came the guilt. It felt like my father was sending a passive-aggressive message from beyond the grave through Fred. And so I made a deal with my dead father. I would mix my mother's ashes in with his if he would just make Fred leave me alone.
但接着内疚感来了。感觉好像我父亲通过弗雷德从坟墓里传达了一个被动攻击的信息。所以我与我死去的父亲做了一个交易。如果他能让弗雷德离我远点，我就把母亲的骨灰和他混在一起。
Back then, I was still going through my father's house. My mother's urn was right there on top of the entertainment center where it had always been. This time no incense, no blue velvet bag.
那时，我还在清理我父亲的房子。我母亲的骨灰瓮就在娱乐中心上面，一直都在那里。这次没有香，没有蓝色天鹅绒袋。
Now, if you're unfamiliar, metal urns are heavy. Their tops screw off, and the grinding sound of metal on metal is louder than you think it's going to be. And it reverberates through your hands.
现在，如果你不熟悉，金属骨灰瓮很重。它们的顶部可以拧下来，金属与金属摩擦的声音比你想象的要大。它在你的手中回荡。
In the movies, the ashes are all loose inside. My mother's ashes had come in a plastic bag clamped together with a metal tag. But after the sound of metal on metal echoed around me and the reverberations rattle my knuckles, I discovered my mother's urn contained no bag and no ashes. The urn was completely empty.
在电影里，骨灰在里面都是松散的。我母亲的骨灰放在一个用金属标签夹在一起的塑料袋里。但在金属与金属的声音在我周围回荡，振动震动我的关节后，我发现我母亲的骨灰瓮里没有袋子，也没有骨灰。骨灰瓮完全是空的。
I don't know if you've ever had ashes suddenly go missing, but it's impossible to search for them in a way that makes sense. At first, it felt a little like looking for my keys. I tried remembering where I saw them last. But they'd only ever been in the one place.
我不知道你是否经历过骨灰突然不见了的情况，但以一种合理的方式搜索它们是不可能的。起初，感觉有点像找钥匙。我试着回忆我最后一次看到它们的地方。但它们一直只在一个地方。
I remembered what a prankster my father had been, often for his own entertainment. So I looked in all the drawers. I even looked in the fridge, places, honestly, I definitely would have seen a bag of ashes that had been there.
我记得我父亲是一个恶作剧者，经常为了自己的娱乐。所以我查看了所有的抽屉。我甚至看了冰箱，说实话，我肯定会看到一个在那里放着的骨灰袋。
Then the panic set in, and I was looking under the couch between the cushions. Then it was coat pockets and any container I could find. I was digging through the pantry because maybe there's another urn that accidentally got mixed in with the cans. Maybe they fell into one of these shoes in the closet. Maybe one of the books on the shelf is hollowed out. She had to be here somewhere.
然后恐慌开始了，我在沙发垫下寻找。然后是外套口袋和任何我能找到的容器。我在储藏室里翻找，因为也许有另一个骨灰瓮不小心混进了罐头里。也许它们掉进了衣柜里的这些鞋子里。也许书架上的一本书是空心的。她一定在某个地方。
I searched the house obsessively for weeks, but I never found her ashes. That's the third time my mother died. Years have gone by, and the truth is I never stopped looking really. There's no urgency anymore, and it's been a long time since I panicked about it. But every so often, I'll reach all the way in the back of a drawer or feel around on top of a cabinet just in case.
我强迫性地搜查房子几周，但我从来没找到她的骨灰。这是我母亲第三次死。几年过去了，事实是我从来没有真正停止过寻找。不再有紧迫感了，我因为这件事恐慌已经是很久以前的事了。但每隔一段时间，我就会把手伸进抽屉的最深处，或者在柜子顶部摸索，以防万一。
Samuel James in Portland, Maine. Samuel is a musician and does these great performances where he tells stories and plays guitar. And you can see those at therealsamueljames.com. He did most of the music for this story.
缅因州波特兰的塞缪尔·詹姆斯。塞缪尔是一位音乐家，做着精彩的表演，讲述故事并弹吉他。你可以在therealsamueljames.com看到这些。他为这个故事做了大部分音乐。
By the way, if you or anybody you know is in crisis or needs help, the suicide and crisis lifeline is available all day and night. Just dial 988. Again, that's 988.
顺便说一句，如果你或你认识的人处于危机中或需要帮助，自杀与危机生命线（Suicide and Crisis Lifeline）全天候开放。只需拨打988。再说一遍，是988。
Act three, "Righteous Gemstone." This next story starts with a move, an apartment search, and a mystery. Bim Adewunmi has the rest of the story.
第三幕，“正义宝石”（Righteous Gemstone）。下一个故事开始于一次搬家、一次公寓搜索和一个谜团。比姆·阿德温米（Bim Adewunmi）有故事的余韵。
When she was 31, Jean got the opportunity to move to Berlin. In a way, she had been preparing for this since she was in middle school in upstate New York. Back then, she'd made a choice.
当她31岁时，琼（Jean）有机会搬到柏林。在某种程度上，她从在纽约州上初中时就开始为这一刻做准备了。那时，她做了一个选择。
You had a choice of three languages, Spanish was for the cool, fun kids, French was for the sophisticates, and German was for the intellectuals. And so obviously, I chose German.
你有三种语言可选，西班牙语是给酷、有趣的孩子选的，法语是给成熟的人选的，德语是给知识分子选的。所以显然，我选了德语。
Because you are an intellectual.
因为你是知识分子。
Yeah.
是的。
OK.
好的。
That's how I envisioned myself at that age.
那就是我那个年龄想象中自己的样子。
Many years later, she got to make use of that choice. She was living in London at the time, working as a copywriter and wanting to shake things up. I knew Jean a little back then. We lived in different corners of London with mutual friends in common. And randomly, months after she moved to Berlin, so did I.
多年后，她有机会利用那个选择。那时她住在伦敦，从事文案工作，想寻求改变。当时我有点了解琼。我们住在伦敦的不同角落，有共同的互惠朋友。巧合的是，在她搬到柏林几个月后，我也搬到了那里。
I was there on a journalism fellowship for only a few months, and we only managed to hang out a couple of times. One of those times was at her apartment. And I remember thinking how amazing it was-- huge windows, solid wood floors, luxuriously large. No one else I knew had an apartment like it.
我在那里参加一个新闻奖学金项目只待了几个月，我们只设法聚了几次。其中一次是在她的公寓里。我记得我想那真是太棒了——巨大的窗户，实木地板，极其宽敞。我认识的人中没人有像它那样的公寓。
I remember thinking to myself, oh, it's huge. Like, it's a cathedral of an apartment.
我记得我对自己想，哦，它太大了。就像，那是一个教堂般的公寓。
It was a very good apartment under the circumstances. It was on Helmholtzplatz, which is a large square in Prenzlauer Berg, which is a sort of chichi kind of neighborhood-- beautiful, old building, kind of classic courtyard style. And yeah, the apartment, it did feel enormous. The living room was huge. The bedroom was huge.
在当时的情况下，那是一个非常好的公寓。它位于赫姆霍兹广场（Helmholtzplatz），那是普伦茨劳贝格（Prenzlauer Berg）的一个大广场，那是一个比较时髦的社区——美丽的旧建筑，经典的庭院风格。是的，公寓确实感觉很大。客厅很大。卧室也很大。
I remember another friend came to visit from England. And I had maybe been there for about five months. And she said, Jean, when are you going to get more furniture? And I said, well, what more furniture do I need? I live here alone.
我记得另一位朋友从英国来访。我可能已经在那里住了五个月了。她说，琼，你打算什么时候买更多的家具？我说，嗯，我还需要什么家具？我一个人住。
Before I go any further with the story, a little context. At the time that we were living in Berlin, it was almost comically hard to find an apartment, especially for foreigners like us. I'd been lucky to find my apartment share in Kreuzberg, thanks to a friend and lucky timing. But Jean lived alone and had somehow found this unicorn of an apartment. And I always wondered, the way so many of us obsess over our friends' apartments, how did she land this?
在我继续讲故事之前，先提供一点背景。在我们住在柏林的时候，找公寓几乎是可笑地困难，特别是对于像我们这样的外国人。多亏了一个朋友和幸运的时机，我幸运地在克罗伊茨贝格（Kreuzberg）找到了我的合租公寓。但琼一个人住，不知何故找到了这套独角兽般的公寓。我一直很好奇，就像我们许多人对朋友公寓的痴迷一样，她是怎么拿到这套房的？
The story of how she found her apartment started the usual way. She saw a listing online, and then went along at a set time on a specific day to view the apartment. Also typical, she was there with about 30 other people, and all of them were her competition for the lease.
她找到公寓的故事以通常的方式开始。她在网上看到了列表，然后在特定的一天特定时间去看公寓。同样典型的是，她和大约30个其他人在一起，他们都是她竞争租约的对象。
And then you have to fill out an application on the spot. So I went to the realtor and said in my halting German, I'm really interested in this apartment. I'd like to fill out an application. But I don't speak German very well, obviously. And so I'd like to take it away, and then I'll submit it. And he just looked at me and shook his head sort of disdainfully, I felt.
然后你必须当场填一份申请表。所以我走到房地产经纪人那里，用我断断续续的德语说，我对这套公寓很感兴趣。我想填一份申请表。但我显然不太会说德语。所以我想把它带走，然后再提交。他只是看着我，摇了摇头，我感觉有点轻蔑。
This disdainful realtor, he tells Jean to write down her information. And if by some miracle one of the many German-speaking and German-writing applicants doesn't get the apartment, he'll call her. So she takes an application form and dutifully writes down her number and her name on his notepad. And without a lot of hope, she walks away.
这位轻蔑的房地产经纪人告诉琼写下她的信息。如果奇迹般地众多讲德语和写德语的申请者中没人拿到公寓，他会给她打电话。于是她拿着申请表，尽职尽责地在他的记事本上写下了她的号码和名字。在没有太多希望的情况下，她走开了。
And then this man chased me into the hallway. And he said, Edelstein. That's such a beautiful name, Edelstein. It's so special.
然后这个男人追我到了走廊。他说，埃德尔斯坦（Edelstein）。那是个多么美丽的名字，埃德尔斯坦。它太特别了。
Edelstein is her last name. And as for why he was fixated on it, well, his next question cleared it up.
埃德尔斯坦是她的姓。至于为什么他执着于它，嗯，他的下一个问题澄清了这一点。
Where are you from? Where is your family from?
你从哪里来？你的家人从哪里来？
Oh. [LAUGHS] A loaded question.
哦。[笑] 一个沉重的问题。
Indeed. That was when I knew what he wanted to know was, are you Jewish?
确实。那是我知道他想知道的时候，你是犹太人吗？
Whether implicitly or explicitly asked, "are you Jewish?" has been historically a notably heavy question. For one thing, it's difficult to discern the intentions of the asker.
无论是否隐晦地提问，“你是犹太人吗？”在历史上一直是一个显著沉重的问题。一方面，很难分辨提问者的意图。
How would you describe the tone of his voice when he said your name? Like was it full of awe maybe? Or what was it?
当他说你的名字时，你会如何描述他语气的调子？是充满了敬畏吗？还是什么？
Yeah. I think awe, excitement, a touch of delight.
是的。我想是敬畏、兴奋，还有一丝愉悦。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
That's a pretty impressive mix of tones. For the past several years before she'd moved to Berlin, Jean had been living in the UK. And while living in London, she'd been the victim of overt anti-Semitic harassment, having slurs thrown at her in person on the street, but also the covert kind-- in her inbox in response to some of her writing. So naturally, she was always listening for vocal inflections.
那是一个相当令人印象深刻的语调组合。在搬到柏林之前的几年里，琼一直住在英国。住在伦敦期间，她是公开反犹太骚扰的受害者，在街上被当面辱骂，也有隐蔽的骚扰——在回应她的一些写作的收件箱里。所以自然地，她总是警惕地倾听语调。
And I said, I think, danke, thank you-- very uncomfortable. And I know, or I felt, that question meant, are you Jewish? And I didn't feel comfortable answering it because despite all of his enthusiasm, I wasn't sure what his intentions were or what his opinions were. Ultimately, when in 2012 a middle-aged German person asked me a question trying to find out if I was Jewish, I felt like what I wanted to ask him was, well, what did your family do during the war?
我想我说，谢谢（danke）——非常不舒服。而且我知道，或者我感觉，那个问题意味着，你是犹太人吗？而且我不觉得回答它很舒服，因为尽管他很热情，但我不知道他的意图是什么，也不知道他的观点是什么。最终，当一个中年德国人在2012年问我一个试图弄清楚我是否是犹太人的问题时，我觉得我想问他的是，嗯，战争期间你家人做了什么？
Jean did not get that apartment. But the next day, Claudia, her friend who had helped her fill out the application, heard from the realtor.
琼没拿到那套公寓。但第二天，帮助她填申请表的朋友克劳迪娅（Claudia）接到了房地产经纪人的电话。
She said, Jean, the realtor called. And he said, Ms. Edelstein, she can't have that apartment, but I have a special apartment for the special Edelstein.
她说，琼，经纪人打电话了。他说，埃德尔斯坦小姐，她拿不到那套公寓，但我有一个特别的公寓给特别的埃德尔斯坦。
The special Edelstein.
特别的埃德尔斯坦。
And Claudia was like, I guess you should find out what's going on. Because she had lived in Berlin for a long time. She knew it was hard to get an apartment.
克劳迪娅觉得，我想你应该查查是怎么回事。因为她在柏林住了很久。她知道找公寓很难。
Right.
没错。
So basically, the realtor said that the apartment downstairs, which was identical to the one that I had seen, would be available. And he would not put it on the market, but hold it for me so that I could have that apartment.
所以基本上，经纪人说楼下的公寓，和我看到的那套一模一样，会空出来。他不会把它放到市场上，而是留给我，这样我就能拿到那套公寓。
So you bypassed the regular--
所以你绕过了正常的——
The whole process. So there were not 39 people besides me in that apartment.
整个过程。所以那套公寓里没有除了我之外的39个人。
Wow. I mean, that's pretty special treatment.
哇。我的意思是，那是非常特殊的待遇。
It was very special.
那是非常特殊的。
For a special lady with a special name.
给一位有特殊名字的特殊女士。
For a special Edelstein.
给一位特别的埃德尔斯坦。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
And that was only the first time Fraulein Edelstein would get a little something extra for her troubles. When it came time to open a bank account in order to get paid at her new job, she went in and spoke to a bank employee.
而且这只是埃德尔斯坦小姐第一次因她的麻烦而得到一点额外的东西。当她为了在新工作中领薪水去开银行账户时，她走进去和一位银行雇员谈话。
And she was just like, ugh. This is going to be very difficult. Maybe we can find time for your appointment. And I was a little anxious because I needed the bank account to get paid. And she said, OK, well, write your name and phone number down, and we'll call you to make an appointment.
她说，啊。这会非常困难。也许我们可以找时间处理你的预约。我有点焦虑，因为我需要银行账户来领工资。她说，好吧，写下你的名字和电话号码，我们会打电话给你预约。
So I did. And then she went, oh, Edelstein. Oh, I'll do it myself.
我写了。然后她说，哦，埃德尔斯坦。哦，我自己来办。
She got an appointment for the next day. And the bank worker made a point to introduce Jean to the bank manager, who shook her hand solemnly, like she was a visiting dignitary or something. But there was more.
她拿到了第二天的预约。银行员工特意把琼介绍给了银行经理，经理严肃地握了她的手，就好像她是来访的贵宾之类的。但还有更多。
And then she said, oh, and let me get you something else. And she gave me a mug, a bank-branded mug to take with me. And I went back to the office. And I was like, hey, guys, I got my bank mug. And everyone else said, I didn't get a mug.
然后她说，哦，让我再给你拿点什么。她给了我一个杯子，一个带有银行标志的杯子让我带走。我回到办公室。我说，嘿，伙计们，我拿到银行杯了。其他人说，我没拿到杯子。
This kept happening, and it led to some odd analogies.
这种情况一直在发生，导致了一些奇怪的类比。
So there's two things I would compare it to. One is being a really hot person, which I am not. I'm a perfectly nice looking person, but I'm not someone where being good looking is my number one defining characteristic. And I have friends who maybe fall in that category. I feel like we've all met them.
所以我可以将它与两件事进行比较。一个是做一个非常性感的人，我不是。我是个长相还不错的人，但我不是那种以长相作为头号定义特征的人。我有属于那一类的朋友。我觉得我们都见过他们。
And you know what it's like, where you go places with them and suddenly people are like, would you like a free drink? Can I upgrade your hotel room? Would you like me to walk around and carry things for you? That sort of thing.
你知道那是什么感觉，当你在某些地方和他们在一起时，突然人们说，要免费饮料吗？我可以帮你升级酒店房间吗？你想要我走来走去帮你拿东西吗？那种事情。
The other thing she'd compare it to, being a B-list celebrity. Getting a smoother experience at the immigration desk at the airport, a sudden discount on a couch-- all things that happened to Jean.
她还会比较的另一件事，是做一个B级名流。在机场移民局得到更顺畅的体验，沙发突然打折——这些都发生在琼身上。
This is so embarrassing. When I was shopping, if I use my debit card and I handed it to somebody in a store, I became used to them looking at it and saying, oh, Edelstein to the extent that I would just naturally pause and wait for this moment of recognition.
这太尴尬了。当我购物时，如果我使用借记卡并把它递给商店里的某个人，我习惯了他们看着它并说，哦，埃德尔斯坦，以至于我会自然地停顿并等待这一刻的承认。
So what was it about her name that unlocked this very specific door? In direct translation, Edelstein means noble stone or precious stone, sometimes used as a synonym for diamond. This made sense to Jean. Some of her ancestors had been jewelers.
那么她的名字到底有什么东西解锁了这个非常特别的门？在直接翻译中，埃德尔斯坦意味着高贵的石头或珍贵的石头，有时用作钻石的同义词。这对琼来说是有意义的。她的一些祖先是珠宝商。
But none of that explained the innate delight it brought out in people. There was just some ineffable cuteness her name held to the average German ear, she was told. It was like being named Jean Adorable. Like some people would giggle with joy when they saw her name.
但这并不能解释它给人们带来的内在喜悦。她被告知，她的名字在德国人的耳朵里有一种难以言表的可爱感。就像被命名为“可爱的琼”。当人们看到她的名字时，有些人甚至会兴奋地咯咯笑。
Did anybody give you anything that felt like a satisfactory answer for why your name held this hold over people?
有人给你一个令人满意的答案解释为什么你的名字对人们有这种控制力吗？
No, not really. They would say, oh, it's very elegant. It's very sweet. It's such a cute name. It's very special. Some people would say it's very old-fashioned. And then I would say, is it because it's Jewish? And they'd say, yeah, that too.
没有，真的。他们会说，哦，它非常优雅。它非常甜。它是一个如此可爱的名字。它非常特别。有些人会说它非常过时。然后我会问，是因为它是犹太名字吗？他们会说，是的，也有那个原因。
But then they would return to the specific sweetness of the name. Jean had this distinct feeling every time someone made a big deal out of her name, like they had been presented with an opportunity. It made her remember a story her older brother, who'd also studied German at school, had told her about a thing he'd noticed while on exchange in Germany when he was 15. Several adults seemed to make a point of mentioning their age to him. Like they'd slip it into conversation in a way that seemed strange. And while he didn't know for sure why, he had a theory.
但随后他们会回到这个名字特殊的甜美感。每当有人大做文章时，琼都有这种独特的感觉，就像他们得到了一个机会。这让她想起她哥哥讲的故事，他也曾在学校学过德语，关于他在15岁时在德国交换期间注意到的事情。几个成年人似乎特意向他提及他们的年龄。就像他们以一种似乎奇怪的方式把它插入谈话中。虽然他不能确定为什么，但他有一个理论。
They wanted him to know that they were too young.
他们想让他知道他们太年轻了。
To have taken part in the horrors?
没参与到恐怖事件中？
Correct.
正确。
Wow.
哇。
The truth of that reality lingered in her mind as she would receive these upticks in customer service, reconciling the extreme pleasantness of these interactions with the uncomfortable possibility of why, never knowing how much of it was the cuteness of her name versus something darker.
当她收到这些客户服务的提升时，那个现实的真相一直徘徊在她的脑海中，协调这些互动中极端的热情与为什么会有这种互动的不舒服的可能性，从不知道其中有多少是名字的可爱，还是更黑暗的东西。
The larger story surrounding having this name, of course, is that there was a crime against humanity perpetrated against bearers of this name and other people with names like Jean's. Some of those people had lived in the very same neighborhood Jean was now living in.
当然，围绕着这个名字的更大故事是，针对这个名字的持有者和其他有像琼这样名字的人，曾经犯下了反人类罪。这些人中的一些人曾经住在琼现在居住的同一个社区。
Many Jewish people were taken from Prenzlauer Berg and killed. There's no nice way to say that. And so on the one hand, there was a sense of pride in reclaiming the space there, but it was uncomfortable.
许多犹太人从普伦茨劳贝格被带走并杀害。没有好听的说法。所以一方面，在这里夺回空间有一种自豪感，但它很不舒服。
And I didn't pursue the story of who was this man who was renting me the apartment? Did he own the apartment? Did his family own the building? How did the person who owned the building gain ownership of the building? I did go to an office to sign a lease, and that person was not Jewish, so.
而且我没去追究那个把公寓租给我的男人是谁？他是公寓的主人吗？他的家人拥有这栋楼吗？那个拥有这栋楼的人是怎么获得所有权的？我确实去了一个办公室签租约，那个人不是犹太人，所以。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah. I felt some mild concern about why I had been given this apartment.
对于我为什么会被给予这套公寓，我感到了一些轻微的担忧。
And the concern was that it felt slightly unfair, or what?
担忧是因为它感觉有点不公平，还是什么？
That it was some kind of reparations that hadn't been discussed with me.
这是某种没有和我讨论过的补偿。
Did you ever think, I actually don't want to know why? Like if I could know, I wouldn't want it to be confirmed.
你有没有想过，我其实不想知道为什么？如果我能知道，我不想它被确认。
Yes. Because I think then it would have made any of these interactions very painful. Because if someone had said to me, I'm doing this because my grandparents did a horrible thing and it makes me feel better, I would have said, this has nothing to do with that. It's not better. You're not fixing anything. So it could remain a sort of funny, slightly dark phenomenon as long as it wasn't interrogated.
是的。因为我认为那样会使这些互动变得非常痛苦。因为如果有人对我说，我这样做是因为我的祖父母做了可怕的事情，这让我感觉好点，我会说，这与那无关。这并不更好。你没有修复任何东西。所以只要它没被审问，它可以保持一种滑稽、略带黑暗的现象。
Jean returned to the US just over a year after moving to Berlin. Back in Brooklyn, she went to a bookstore, where she was asked for her name to sign up to the mailing list.
琼在搬到柏林一年多后回到了美国。回到布鲁克林，她去了一家书店，在那里她被问及名字以注册到邮件列表。
And I said, Edelstein. And they were just like, OK, and typed it out.
我说，埃德尔斯坦。他们只是，哦，好的，然后输入了它。
What do you feel then?
那你那时候感觉如何？
Humbled.
谦卑。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
I felt so humbled.
我感到如此谦卑。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. Brooklyn is full of Steins, and Steins, and Steins even. It didn't make me special anymore.
是的。布鲁克林到处都是斯坦、斯坦和斯坦。它不再让我变得特别了。
Jean doesn't miss that old frisson that passed through her when she said her name in Berlin. She stopped pronouncing her name the German way, Edelstein, within weeks of returning home. The lack of reaction was her welcome home sign. And everybody knows the big reason why home is special is that nobody treats you like you're special.
琼并不怀念她在柏林说出名字时传遍她全身的那种旧的战栗感。她在回国几周后就停止用德语发音，埃德尔斯坦（Edelstein）。那种缺乏反应是她的欢迎回家标志。每个人都知道家之所以特别的重大原因是，没人把你当特别的人对待。
Bim Adewunmi is a producer on our program. Jean Hannah Edelstein tells this story and others in her memoir. It's called This Really Isn't About You.
比姆·阿德温米是我们节目的制片人。琼·汉娜·埃德尔斯坦（Jean Hannah Edelstein）在她的回忆录中讲述了这个故事和其他故事。书名是《这真的不是关于你》（This Really Isn't About You）。
Our program was produced today by Ike Sriskandarajah. The people who put together today's program include James Bennett the Second, Phia Bennin, Jendayi Bonds, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Bethel Habte, Kyla Jones, Tobin Low, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alix Spiegel, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
我们的节目今天由艾克·斯里坎达拉贾（Ike Sriskandarajah）制作。今天节目的人员包括詹姆斯·班尼特二世（James Bennett II）、菲亚·本宁（Phia Bennin）、詹达伊·邦兹（Jendayi Bonds）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、迈克尔·科米特（Michael Comite）、贝瑟尔·哈布特（Bethel Habte）、凯拉·琼斯（Kyla Jones）、托宾·洛（Tobin Low）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、娜迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）、瑞安·鲁梅瑞（Ryan Rumery）、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）、弗朗西斯·斯旺森（Frances Swanson）、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）、朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）和黛安·吴（Diane Wu）。我们的总编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman）。我们的资深编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里（Emanuele Berry）。
Special thanks to Eric Winkler, Brett Wean, Barbara Sangreto, Henry Kellerman, Jonathan Otto, Robert Greenspan, and Bob White at WYPR in Baltimore. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free. Free, do you hear me? Also, you'll find new merch, including the colorful and wonderful Torey Malat-shirt. Again, thisamericanlife.org.
特别感谢埃里克·温克勒（Eric Winkler）、布雷特·威恩（Brett Wean）、芭芭拉·桑格雷托（Barbara Sangreto）、亨利·凯勒曼（Henry Kellerman）、乔纳森·奥托（Jonathan Otto）、罗伯特·格林斯潘（Robert Greenspan）和巴尔的摩WYPR的鲍勃·怀特（Bob White）。我们的网站thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体播放我们超过800集的存档。免费，你听到了吗？此外，你会找到新的商品，包括多彩且精彩的托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）T恤。再说一遍，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, theater casting is just amazing these days. And he got the role of Maria in West Side Story, the one who sings "I feel pretty, oh, so pretty." Torey has a great voice, but after a couple of rehearsals he told the director it wasn't for him.
《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所交付给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，现在的戏剧选角真是太棒了。他得到了《西区故事》（West Side Story）中玛丽亚（Maria）的角色，那个唱“我感觉很漂亮，哦，如此漂亮”的人。托里有一副好嗓子，但在几次排练后，他告诉导演那不适合他。
I'm not someone where being good looking is my number one defining characteristic.
我不是那种以长相作为头号定义特征的人。
Back next week with more stories of This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Good day.
下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。我是艾拉·格拉斯。祝好。
Only now you know the rest of the story.
现在，你知道了故事的余韵。